hallo meine lieben freunde der guten
oder was geht ab jetzt willkommen zurück
zu einem neuen video in einem der
letzten videos habe ich 800 euro im
casino gewonnen und das geld habe ich
jetzt für eine mystery box von saturn
ausgegeben willkommen zur ersten folge
von einem neuen format in dem ich
probiere mich von dem casino geld zu
einer rolex hoch zu handeln ob das
klappt wie lange das dauert und wie ich
das mache erfahrt ihr in diesem wie
jeder weiß ich brauche eine rolex weil
erst dann bin ich cool und dann können
mich die leute endlich akzeptieren für
das was ich bin wir brauchen
und aus diesem grund habe ich 800 euro
für einem ist die box ausgegeben ob das
eine gute idee war er nicht das muss
jedem klar sein dieses system macht nur
sinn wenn der kram drin ist der weniger
wert ist als 800 euro aber ich musste
mich anders hätte starten sollen
deswegen machen wir jetzt diese wissen
sie box traum wäre halt wenn saturn
einfach keine lust hätte diese
günstigeren produkte zu verkaufen oder
einfach keine möglichkeit hatte mehr
loszuwerden ich aber über ebay mehr als
800 euro herausbekommen
das wäre ich habe auch schon videos
gesehen bei leuten zum beispiel bei alex
wieder waren iphone in der mystery bock
macht so auf dass ihr nicht direkt sehen
könnt wir brauchen im büro unbedingt
eine kaffeemaschine und ich dachte es
wäre soweit und wir hatten eine
kaffeemaschine aber es ist keine
kaffeemaschine sondern ein kennwort mixa
ich habe keine ahnung was das wert ist
also es könnte sein
ich hatte jetzt halt natürlich auch
irgendwas gehofft wie lay station iphone
irgendwie sowas womit ich selber etwas
anfangen kann oder wofür ich mich selber
begeistern kann aber küchengeräte ich
glaube dafür gibt es immer abnehmer und
wenn man die noch ein bisschen günstiger
bei mir auf ebay kaufen kann als im
laden
könnte das echt gut seid euch direkt mal
schauen was ist ja immer noch die gehen
so zwischen 236 und 250 euro wenn
mindest im neuen verkauf wenn ich dafür
200 bekomme wäre das also perfekt das
ding ist ja komplett neu also ich würde
jetzt mal 200 euro davon auf die banken
ja du hast 802 1p noch 600 euro
ja so 80 gb micro sd das ist so eine sd
karte ist die man für 23 euro kauft also
mit könnt ihr richtig gut preise machen
wir haben ja auch immer für 20 euro an
der kasse dabei sind die 1 euro wäre
also das ist wirklich gar nichts wert
ich tu mal fünf euro mit auf unsere bank
bei der sd karte hat sich diese saturn
aber nämlich was gedacht mir arien von
action kamera und ich glaube gar nicht
mal so eine beschissene hier ist nämlich
ein bildschirm mit dran also das muss
eine der neueren generation ihr seid ja
so ein gopro konkurrent einfach genau
aber auch schon immer deutlich
schlechter als control gewesen trotz
alledem jetzt zum winter wenn wieder
mehr leute ski fahren und so können wir
damit tatsächlich ein bisschen geld
machen zwischen 50 und 80 euro o mein
gott wie günstig ist auch der
geisteskranke also ist eine gute
alternative bestimmte irgend jemanden
der nicht so viel ausgeben will man uns
ist weniger gut 48 euro ist hier das
niedrigste also packe ich 48 euro
zubehör okay das könnte den preis
vielleicht ein bisschen höher werden
lassen und das eigentlich ganz cool
erwachsener mit auf die bank wir müssen
jetzt ragen wie bei 270 euro oder so
sein ich habe langsam schiffweiler es
schlecht ist viel wert wird
rommelsbacher reise tauchsieder hat
gefragt was ich das überhaupt klar es
ist zum wasser heiß machen ich werde
jetzt nicht googeln aber das einfach mal
auf zehn euro oder so schätzen sun des
wearable mp3-player oh mein gott
back to the future alter würden das ist
2004 geht gerade hier so ein bisschen
der arsch auf grundeis weil ich nicht
weiß was ich mit dem geld gemacht habe
als ich hätte vieles anstellen können
was definitiv schlauer gewesen wäre als
das bisher für 800 euro zu kaufen das
war ja eine stabile erste folge wenn ich
alles verkaufen würde und weniger geld
hätte
wer so perfekt ok sony boxe ich glaube
gar nicht so ein mega altes modell
funktioniert gut die slice dieses
wasserdicht und ich glaube tatsächlich
dass man so was auch ganz gut verkauft
bekommen hat die extra also ist nice to
have und lässt sich bestimmt gut
verkaufen aber auf 1800 euro kommen wir
dann mit diesen ganzen kram immer noch
nicht wir haben zum glück noch eine
zweite zweite frage schnell was die box
kostet bevor wir uns dann um das finale
und natürlich das beste produkt gewarnt
habe mir das bis zum schluss aufgespart
und ich kann überhaupt nicht einschätzen
was wert also hier das richtige arsch
[ __ ] entweder ich kümmere mich jetzt
darum dass ich die sachen zurück geben
kann was ja eigentlich nicht möglich ist
oder ich bin halt wirklich nach der
ersten folge bei weniger als ich
gestartet
wie weit kann man sich in drei youtube
videos davon entfernen eine rolex zug
auf 125 euro die box niedrigster preis
ok ist das hier ist der gesamte bank
account den wir jetzt für unsere rolex
mit diesen produkten haben geht was das
letzte com
neben ein wenig verpackungsmaterial und
einer rechnung haben hier doch letztes
programm können
kirche ein handy uhr beim asics es mit
leica kam mit leica camera ich habe
keine ahnung wie viel das wert ist was
das für ein handy ist aber die
verpackung sieht nice aus und das ist
ein handy das bedeutet es ist schon mal
zumindest ein bisschen was wert weißt du
was ich denke huawei ist vielleicht
nicht zu preis stabil wie iphones oder
so was definitiv check auch da noch mal
was das kostet aber es ist nice wir
haben wenigstens ein handy dabei
bekommen macht unseren insgesamten preis
für alle produkte zieht das mit
sicherheit hoch wie viel das werden wir
jetzt erfahren ich kann euch so viel
schon mal sagen wie von anfang an gesagt
das system macht keinen sinn wenn dinge
drin sind die mehr wert sind als das was
man bezahlt habe das war mir bewusst
aber ich wollte es natürlich trotzdem
auf
und ich habe ein geschätztes alter das
sieht müssen jetzt etwas neues zu sein
und waterpark wieviel wenig oder viel
what the [ __ ] korsage und sprich wird
uns 1700 euro was das ist dieses klappt
mein gott herr otte fahrt also soll ich
das auch machen nein auf gar keinen fall
du kannst es viel teurer verkaufen wenn
es zu ist er jetzt sind jetzt notwendig
das handy ist was würde das für einen
sinn machen das für die da rein zu tun
hatte fach das ist das 512 gb speicher 8
gigabyte ram oder das gehirn handy zum
aufklappen deswegen bei saturn 1700 euro
1700 leute ich war dabei date hat das
paket so geöffnet und so ist für alle
manipuliert oder sonst wirst du alle
kanal mitglieder ich lade dieses video
hier was wir gerade gefilmt haben in
ungeschnittener form extra für euch wo
ihr könnt checken das ist alles
hundertprozentig packt euch
bestätigungen mit rechnungen und so in
das video rein
hier ist nichts gefälliger 1700 euro job
mit wenn ich das verkaufen würde könnte
ich mir sofort irgendeine 36 mm zu
schaffen
das schafft somit gezittert
also ich dachte der zug werk komplett
abgefahren ich hab das war ja schon die
ganze zeit in der box gesehen und ich
dachte okay neu ist jetzt ist noch so
ein 200 euro bildung huawei drin aber
what the [ __ ] also 1700 euro und trotz
alledem bitte gebt euer eigenes geld
nicht für so etwas aus das ist nicht der
normalfall der du hast immer so glück
bei so einer scheiße underdog leute das
ist nicht normal gespielt also insgesamt
haben wir jetzt diese ganzen produkte in
unserer saturn misery box bekommen und
jetzt heißt es aus diesen produkten so
viel geld machen wie es nur geht es ist
sehr viel trash dabei den ich probiere
so schnell wie es geht los zu werden es
sind aber auch sachen dabei wo ich
natürlich darauf achten muss dass ich
einen angemessenen preis bekomme und
jetzt heißt es die sachen verkaufen und
dann möglichst schnell richtung rolex
als alles ist fotografiere ich hätte
ganz sachen packt die einfach bei ebay
kleinanzeigen rein schauen was wir dafür
bekommt dann bin ich bestimmt in einer
anderthalb stunden schon fertig damit
die ganzen sachen eingestellt haben ich
bin extrem gespannt aufs leute gibt die
es kaufen werden denn die ganzen sachen
sind ja noch originalverpackt aber trotz
alledem weise jetzt nicht wer bereit ist
1700 euro für huawei ja das könnte hat
auch das problem sein also wir sind auf
jeden fall die über dem preis was wir
ausgegeben haben aber wie nahe wir an
unserer rolex dran sind das weiß ich
noch nicht sieben tage ist es
mittlerweile her dass sich die mystery
box aufgemacht hat mit diesen ganzen
sachen hier drin ich konnte tatsächlich
den großteil verkaufen und wir sind
deutlich über 800 euro diese
küchenmaschine wird heute um 18 uhr 30
persönlich abgeholt für 200 euro diese
box haben wir für 75 inklusive versand
verkauft und das handy für 1280 euro das
macht einen preis von keine ahnung wir
sind der rolex in diesem video deutlich
näher gekommen sind trotzdem aber noch
meilenweit entfernt ich habe aber auf
dem video 2 schon eine idee die jeden
rahmen sprengt ihr ist ist diese paar
sachen hier also kamera mit zubehör
mp3-player und so sind nicht weggegangen
der tauchsieder komischerweise auch
nicht das ist aber kein problem das hat
er den geringsten preis ausgemacht ich
freue mich extrem auf video zweier wenn
ihr das nicht verpassen wollt vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren und mich
auf der reise zu begleiten bis ich eine
rolex anstatt dieser apple watch trage
vielen dank fürs anschauen
bis zum nächsten mal kurz der reinste
traum wie das hier funktioniert hat